ah oui
tu te sens d'être ici est ce que c'est
la première fois que tu fais le festival
de cannes c'est pas ma première fois
mais je suis très excité de voir ce film
et de personnes des tarn et garonnais
on est attendus et j'ai hâte de voir se
terminer et qu'est ce qui est spécial
cannes jean quel est le sentiment que ça
ici l'énergie racontez nous un point
j'adore laquelle moi c'est décalé pour
sont retrouvés énorme robe jusqu'à
d'infimes c5 est rigolo c'est un
puncheur de grandes comédies sortes de
pièces de théâtre dont on est tous les
acteurs et c'est assez rigolo de maxime
à total mais je suis très très très très
très nerveuse
ils soient manager
c'est pas bien ça va tu es trop bête et
rigole un gainage